you have three-year-old twins I do yeah
three-year-old twins yeah doing well
this is not a police interview and what
time did you last see them here's my
question for you because I've you're you
we've talked about this before and I'm
not trying to embarrass you but you are
one of the sharpest comedy minds out
there she's amazingly fabulous for
someone as quick as you how do you slow
and slow how do you judge your kids
sense of humor do they have a good sense
of humor can you tell what it is yet at
the age of three I actually think they
might have terrible senses of humor
you can tell that already well yeah I
mean I was sitting right before I came
here today on the couch with my son Max
and he was watching Peppa Pig Peppa Pig
are you not familiar I'm not there
everyone's laughing at me I don't know
who kept I do not know who Peppa Pig is
okay well Peppa Pig is a big deal in her
house and it's a little pig named Peppa
mm-hmm anyway you said you should write
for TV Guide yeah there was a moment
where there was water just like falling
on Peppa's head mhm
my son Max could not handle what he was
seeing
he was cackling in this high pitch
laughs that way I I thought I was
missing something that was really the
extent wait a minute he's three there's
this we're talking about three year old
so maybe that you know it's yeah sure it
could be an age thing but
my wife is very funny and I guess we
just thought we would get more okay are
you able to make your kids laughed in
that do they laugh at you you know you
have kind of a very dry subtle sense of
humor do they laugh at the stuff that
you do no I you wouldn't believe
actually how much I have to hack it up
for them like the voices I do I the the
the way my body whatever I am doing it's
so over the top and right I get a little
bit of something but then you turn on
Peppa and they're like Peppa's father in
one episode is going to press a button
to take the top off is convertible
mmm-hmm but it makes the windshield
wipers go uh-huh
I'm loving it right now I love that that
is not what's supposed to happen usually
it gets funny check out Peppa Pig